hello freak [ __ ] have you been paying
attention to what's going on with Bill
Nye scientists are all going after Bill
Nye Bill Nye the weimar guy the why Marv
yeah which is why why Marv Germany is
right before Hitler was all decadent and
like everyone's you know just completely
loose and culture liberal and he's
having these dancers about talking about
their vagina to white mark that was what
was ridiculous it's not even a scientist
no he's not yeah it's he's a a con man
isn't he an engineer yeah but he's not
at climatologist he's not a scientist
and he's also changing his tune there
was a steven crowder did a bit about it
where he showed the original show that
he did many years ago where they talked
about and how gender is from chromosomes
there's double X which is men and XY or
women and XY which is men right and
they're establishing what causes your
gender right and now he's completely
gone off of that and his new thing had
this woman who belonged in some [ __ ]
Venice theater group like grey barking
out at a poetry slam some unbelievably
god-awful song and this [ __ ] put
it on Netflix on a science show about
gender and he pretended to be like a DJ
in the background like this is so not
science right it's so naughty well as
insulting progressivism is just
Christianity without the root mythology
so it's it's very much this kind of
Christian ideal a radical progressive is
corrective angelica professor was
specifically I don't mean someone who's
like blazing welfare I mean there's this
ideology that he's fallen into yeah with
the complete religion which has
completely divorced from reality
and stuff like this it's it's full
left-wing I mean I think there's there's
great ideas in being progressive there's
some amazing ideas in terms of
inclusiveness yeah in terms of yes live
and let live but letting people be
whoever they want express yourselves in
any way that you've seen see fit as long
as it's not hurting other but that's
that they all good to the propaganda
it's meant to be prop again what is his
show his show yes if you know what that
is I think what he's doing is licking
his finger
finding out which way the wind is
blowing and giving in to those people
now I think he's a true believer because
you have to be a true believer to put
something like that out under your name
I think this is a good idea it's just
like if like Christian rock I think it's
debatable I honestly think
these people especially a guy like him
who was experiencing life in the public
eye fairly late in life right and you
know and he when when it comes to people
that are really enthusiastic about
science and really enthusiastic about
these ideas that he's trying to push on
a show other than this janitor thing
you're dealing with the great majority
of them are liberal great majority and
I'm sure he encounters a tremendous
amount of pressure to be inclusive and
gender is the hot topic when it comes to
like weird science as it were like
trying to figure out like how much of
this is what people feel how much of
this can be explained in genetics how
much this can be explained with
sociology how much of it is nature how
much of it is nurturing it's a very
complex stew of human beings and we know
for a fact that people very broadly yes
we have there's a wide spectrum of human
behavior and likes and needs and
feelings and in all sorts of weird dis
Morpheus right we don't know why people
behave the way they behave so for him to
like boil it down to like one of the
shittiest rap songs the world has ever
known
right it's an insult but I think that's
my point is that I think you have to
kind of drank the kool-aid to be putting
this out as your product
maybe I'm less cynical than you I don't
know that could be it I feel like you've
been influenced by really well I think
the people that are super progressive
are far more likely to push these ideas
in a very enthusiastic way yes then
people who are more conservative in
these matters it's not good even
approach him about this right you know I
feel like he's just been influenced by
the influencers well certainly getting
rewarded for it once you get rewarded
for something your brain gets a feedback
loop and it's trying to kind of sell
validating so that could be a
[Applause]
[Music]